I mean the whole Daily Briefing is an
act in the first place like the
president uh President Clinton started
the daily the White House briefings and
it was basically like the 24-hour news
Cycles came out they needed stuff coming
out of the White House consistently
content and it became like I started
working at NBC in 201 uh end of 2012.
and I decided to leave the cable news
game because I was like this is such BS
because it's you pay you play pay your
dues you ask the right questions and if
you ask the right questions you play the
game for long enough then you'll you'll
be one of those front men right so you
just have to play the game
in cohorts with the White House and so
it's like this relationship between the
fourth estate and the government that is
the exact opposite of the purpose of the
press which is like to you know ask the
tough question I think they should just
get rid of it it's it's TV time
for oh yes reporters that's all it is
because they have a press office yeah
they should do a tick tock briefing